the most important question I would ask
any individual would be do you think
you're important me know what your value
I mean do you what do you do you see
yourself as an individual do you see
yourself as a member of a pressure group
as a member of a political party is a
member of a church there's a faith as a
you you see yourself in family terms as
a parent a child and uncle a lover in
personal terms how do you see you so do
you see yourself as a instrument of good
you feel like you're a person that's
always on the defense that people have
to get you or you're on the offense
you're out there you know making your
own world doing your own things you feel
that that there are certain things that
others old you family may owe you guy
next door male you the government may
owe you do you feel there things that
you owe others when something goes wrong
who do you blame automatically do you
ever feel you're responsible for your
own mistakes
you